Over the past two decades, K-12 school
reform has been dominated by testing,
standards, and charter schooling. Those
have been the fault lines in the
education reform wars. Well, we've
come to a pivot point.
The new center of gravity? Mindset and race.
This shift was made explicit in my annual
education scholar rankings, which this year made
clear a changing of the guard — not just in policy
and public opinion, but even in terms
of who gets hailed as an expert
in terms of book sales, media
coverage, and more. The shift is not from
advocates to critics of yesterday's
reforms. It's a matter of a shift away
from one set of reforms and towards a
new set of priorities. Education's big shift
is not just about new legislation,
political agendas, and public opinion,
but it extends to who gets celebrated as
an expert. That has big implications for
what research gets conducted and which
ideas are likely to shape the national
discourse in the decade to come.
What do you think is the most promising
reform to improve American schooling?
Let us know in our poll. Also let us know
what other topics
you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.